you're all right yes i'm fine why you
look like melted ice cream
movie magic never fails to amaze us and
we were surprised to learn how many
times
it's actually fooled us the ways tv and
movies managed to trick us into
believing what we're seeing is real
are varied and impressive which actors
abs were courtesy of cgi
what about the body double who hid
another actor's pregnancy
we're covering all that and more so
let's have a look at the most surprising
physical transformations
that totally fooled us it's crazy right
matthew lewis aka neville longbottom
deceived us in all the latter films the
actor had hit puberty a bit earlier than
everyone else
and grew to be lean and handsome not so
on brand with the neville longbottom we
all knew
why is it always me in order to make the
character more believable and
familiar-looking
lewis wore body padding had plastic bits
placed behind his ears so they stuck out
more
and even wore fake teeth the teeth were
only for the prisoner of azkaban though
harry melling or as we know him dudley
dursley
was almost recast in the deathly hallows
film because he had lost so much weight
about 60 pounds that he was almost
unrecognizable
and certainly didn't look the part of
the bumbling and chubby dursley
as opposed to recasting they put him in
a fat suit so he looked more like he had
before
where is your mum where is your mom
potter
we don't blame them since we could
hardly recognize him when he appeared on
our screens while watching the queen's
gambit
this may be one of the best examples of
a convincingly real cgi costume
brie larson in avengers end game appears
on screen
in a fully cgi suit this wound up being
the case because
she had shot her scenes for end game
before she'd begun production for
captain marvel
due to that the costume hadn't actually
finished being designed yet
am i allowed to tell you that i mean
it's kind of complicated
although he'd worn the suit before by
the last movie the famous iron man suit
was computer generated onto his body
robert downey jr did still wear a
partial suit called a football suit
while the rest was cgi magic i'm the
best
though this wasn't the only instance of
cgi in the film
the actor was injured while shooting so
the last scene in the film
is actually a body double in place for
the actor
with robert downey jr's face
superimposed on it
when emma stone was playing the famous
tennis player billie jean king
in the film battle of the sexes the
production required someone who could
realistically play like a pro
so they had a body double step in place
for the intense tennis scenes
all i think about us the body double
worked with the real billie jean king
to learn how she played and moved
physically
the visceral and powerful walk of shame
seen in game of thrones
used body double to portray lena heady
the actress was slightly pregnant at the
time
hidy did perform the scene while wearing
a beige slip and the body double rebecca
van cleave
did the same only in the nude shame
shame shame afterwards cgi was used to
combine hidey's facial expressions
with van cleeve's body while angelina
jolie has performed many nude scenes in
her career
when it came to wanted it was another
body we saw
i'm sorry you apologized too much
sorry about that the actress was sick
the day they shot the scene and wasn't
up for the task
so a body double stepped in while many
people
thought cgi was used to make chris
sullivan appear slimmer in the fourth
season of this is us
the truth is what we saw was what
sullivan really looks like
i've been going to the gym over the last
few months
it came as a shock to learn that
sullivan actually wore prosthetics
throughout the first
few seasons to make him appear larger
than he was
the production did face some criticism
for it but his co-star chrissy metz
defended the decision by explaining that
with all the actors that had read
sullivan was the best for the part in
the end while zachary levi worked out
and got into very good shape
he admitted the shazam suit was padded
to make him look more buff
it's a bit obvious as well looking at
the outfit that it isn't
very realistic considering how sculpted
it is
you have bullet immunity when penelope
cruz was on set for pirates of the
caribbean four
she was pulling double duty as an actor
and
an expecting mother since she was
pregnant she wasn't able to shoot all
the scenes herself
so they used a body double luckily the
double had many similarities to cruz
who also happened to be a cruise the
double was the younger sister of
penelope
monica cruz truly a family affair
you still love me if you had a sister
and a dog
i'd choose the dog while some people
thought only parts of will smith's genie
body were cgi
according to smith nothing but the face
was his own
the entire body was done with cgi
as for the bodybuilder genie again not
smith
but his body double adam basil i said i
was the most
powerful being in the universe before
filming began
it was decided that the green lantern
suit would be entirely cgi
representing the life force coming out
from within the body
reynolds did wear a special suit while
filming which was then covered by cgi
after the fact
it was the only way to do it and i think
it was a fresh way to do it as well
the child actress was required to wear a
fat suit for the filming of little miss
sunshine
yes that's correct the 10 year old
actress
wore a fat suit the production felt it
was important to include because of the
scene in which she's self-conscious and
judgmental of her physical appearance
i think i can win i do then you're gonna
be a winner
when emma thompson did love actually the
director had pictured her character as
frumpy and motherly so the actress was
padded up to be about a size 8 for the
film
since paul walker tragically passed away
in a car accident
and there were still key scenes to shoot
for fast and furious 6
the production resorted to very complex
cgi to bring his face to the screen
his two brothers caleb and cody actually
stepped up to help
since the brothers were close enough to
walk her physically they acted as body
doubles
and then walker's face was superimposed
with cgi
from the prior footage they had of the
actor because you can leave without
saying goodbye
[Music]
when damon was shooting the martian he
was required to look famished and
starved as an astronaut who had been
surviving
on very little for a very long time it
has been seven days since i ran out of
ketchup
due to an intense shooting schedule the
actor wasn't able to quickly lose the
weight he needed to for
filming the scene so a body double was
used instead
though only for about two scenes
according to daemon
betany's vision character successfully
brought to life
a semi-human semi-artificial seeming
character
all of which was achieved by extensive
prosthetics and cgi
the prosthetics took about three and a
half hours to complete
each day it's a little light being
inside a gin and tonic
there is a bit of mystery surrounding
this case
since nicholas cage and the production
team have said that they didn't cgi his
absent ghost rider
but behind the scenes photos seemed to
tell another story
what we do know for sure is that some
cgi was definitely
used to alter his body since it was used
to remove all of his tattoos
toby maguire was meant to shave his head
for the film but since it wasn't in his
contract
he asked the film to pay him fifteen
thousand dollars to do the chop i've
never run a convertible before
they refused and wound up giving him a
bald cap to wear and used
cgi for his hair instead which wound up
being more expensive than the 15 000
would have been anyway
we'll be leaving now you're not going
anywhere pretty boy
keanu reeves prison muscles were
shockingly realistic
but were ultimately prosthetics that
took multiple hours to apply
along with that he also wore a full body
suit with more prosthetics on it
hollywood definitely had us fooled were
you suspect of any of these surprising
body transformations
which movie magic body surprised you the
most let us know in the comments
make sure to click the subscribe button
and give us a like if you enjoyed